la sede del parlamento federal en
cambiarra y acompañado de ministros y
representantes de las comunidades
aborígenes el Primer Ministro de
Australia laborista Anthony albanís y
reveló la pregunta que tendría el
referendo que fue una de sus principales
promesas de campaña en 2022 los
australianos serían convocados este año
para responder esta pregunta y hablo
comillas propuesta de ley modificar la
Constitución para reconocer a los
primeros pueblos de Australia mediante
el establecimiento de una voz aborigen
isleña del estrecho de torres a prueba
esta modificación propuesta cierro
comillas el proyecto de legislación se
presentará la próxima semana al
parlamento y se debatirá en junio por
eso existe la posibilidad de que las
palabras de la pregunta cambien el voto
en Australia es obligatorio Así que
todos los ciudadanos mayores de 18 años
tendrán que votar pero para que el
referendo sea exitoso tendrá que haber
un resultado afirmativo por mayoría
doble que tanto la mayoría de los
votantes nacionales como la mayoría de
los estados voten sí es decir cuatro de
los seis estados que será aprobado se
reconocerá a los pueblos indígenas en la
Constitución nacional que Data de 1901 y
se creará un organismo denominado la voz
que los representará ante el ejecutivo y
el parlamento sus integrantes serán
elegidos por las comunidades locales y
ejercerán sus funciones por un periodo
determinado el Primer Ministro albanís y
dijo que se trata de hacer justicia ya
que por décadas los gobiernos han
intentado imponer sus decisiones en
lugar de consultar a la población
indígena que históricamente ha
enfrentado maltrato desigualdad y
discriminación desde la llegada de los
británicos en 1770 Los aborígenes
representan el 3,2% de los más de 25
millones de habitantes de Australia y
según una encuesta de La Firma essential
publicada por el diario de Guardian esta
semana el 59% de los australianos apoya
la creación de la voz indígena en el
parlamento